and our european neighbors will of
course be watching us on sunday after
all the election outcome in europe's
biggest economy will possibly affect eu
policies and the blocks handling of the
eurozone debt crisis when asgard
berkeley joins us now he's a financial
market expert at the duisburg essen
university and you're also one of
germany's 62 eligible voter or 62
million eligible voters how easy or how
difficult is it this year to cast your
ballots a lot of people seem undecided
so i think this year it's rather
difficult to distinguish between the
social drama democrats and merkels the
merkel party cdu
because they both enacted all the euro
rescue measures voting for austerity
measures in the south and at the same
time for very expansionary monetary
policies of the ecb
and hence it's rather difficult really
to to cast the vote on one of these
parties and we also have the anti-euro
party around
which may be member of the parliament
with the probability of 30 percentage
points but it will not matter in the
long run
but
we just heard here in the report that
all these issues don't really seem to be
at the forefront at least of german
voters they seem to be discussing
minimum wage and taxes and energy
policies uh with regards to the minimum
wage we just heard two contradicting
views one saying it would destroy jobs
the other one saying it would create
them who's right i think the reality is
in between because if you look closer
closer at the issues you would easily
see that the branch level matters even
the firm level matters
because wages have to be set according
to productivity of a worker and if wages
are too high minimum wages are too high
you produce unemployment and then you
have a vicious circle
non-wage labor costs going up to finance
all this unemployment producing again
additional unemployment so you should
really go for the branch never
negotiation of wages and what about
taxes again there are some people saying
that there should be higher taxes for
the higher earners
the money could be then invested into
education or infrastructure and others
say we germans already pay far too much
and the recently uh reported record
revenue income revenue uh by the german
uh finance ministry seemed to confirm
that
at the moment we see sufficient tax
revenues around so there's no issue of
raising taxes we have to really cope
with the future and to take care of our
future in germany we are the business
cycle locomotive at least the other
countries expect it to be
so we should go for more investment
expenditure instead of raising taxes
there's a lack of it in the university
sector in
all the other infrastructure combined
with yeah streets in the in the coal
area and if we do that
we would attract many workers from the
south and by this help the southern
countries and this would be an offer for
the countries as you mentioned the
southern countries the debt
written countries from a european
perspective just briefly who should win
sunday's election
i think what we will see is a grand
coalition this might be not to a bad
thing
because they both went together to to
try to solve the euro area crisis and
can go on with that a grand coalition
and then answer belgium thank you very
much